hi there Steve Kaufman here I want to
talk about and I this is connected with
of course the linguist on language blogs
I want to talk about an issue that's
come up in response to a video that I
did a little earlier where I said that
language learning is not about
performance and of course this has
attracted a lot of a lot but some
criticism from people who say that you
know performance is very important
people have come at me and said that you
know you are a dilettante this one I
don't always Harry or Billy or people
I've got commenting on my blog they're
saying that you know obviously my
knowledge I think was Harry said because
I only know 4,000 characters in Chinese
that Chinese people would respect me and
I butcher the language and all kind of
stuff like that how well do we need to
speak a language well it depends the
answer is it depends what you want to do
it's perfectly legitimate to just want
to take a peek at a language and see
what it's all about
just to get a little bit of a sense of
the language just because you're
interested perfectly legitimate you may
want to learn enough in order to order a
beer and find the bathroom I personally
don't do that because I find that you
know if I go to a place with a few
phrases I'm pretty soon overwhelmed with
whatever the native comes back to me
with so so my own preference in learning
is to get to a point where I can
communicate comfortably on a fairly wide
range of subjects I also find that
learning a language is a sort of I often
say it's it's a it's a
the famous myth of sisyphus and i can't
remember whether he was the one pushing
the rock up the hill that kept on
rolling down or he was in a cave and the
water lever level kept on rising I can
one of these Greek myths the point is
you'll never achieve perfection no
matter how long you spend at it you'll
always wish you were a little better so
given that that's the case you may as
well enjoy whatever level you have and
if you want to stop there that's your
choice so it's not for others to
criticize your level in the language
language learning to me should be a
personal thing something you do for your
own enjoyment now granted there may be
situations for school or to get a job or
you have to achieve a certain level of
fluency and typically of course this
level of fluency is measured in some
kind of grammar test or whatever but
even there I'm convinced that people who
approach language learning with
intention of enjoying it and exposing
themselves to a lot of content listening
and reading and enjoying it and
communicating with people without
worrying it worrying about it those
people will do better and I've mentioned
before that in Canada when they because
they have a bilingual fullness they'll
test Anglophones on their french and if
they can't use the subjunctive correctly
then they don't get their Frank French
your bonus or they don't qualify as
bilingual which of course is just
typically ridiculous ridiculous there
are lots of people who won't get the
subjunctive right and who can
communicate very effectively and who are
not afraid to use the language and there
will be those who will pass their test
on the subjunctive and won't open their
mouth because they're so concerned about
speaking perfectly so to my mind how
well do we speak the language
do we need to speak it as well as you
want do we need to be perfect in order
to say were fluent no we need to be able
to communicate comfortably
and we ourselves are the best judge of
when we are comfortable in a language
and so therefore I'm against people
competing in their performance this
idiot and I'll say he's an idiot this
hairy guy telling me the unit you need
to have 8,000 characters and that I'm
butchering the language I don't care
Harry how well you speak Chinese and you
shouldn't care how well I speak Chinese
and this gets back to this other issue
of a remark that was attributed to cap
sumoto who is a very well known figure
intern in language learning circles on
the web and who has is approach to
language learning much of which I agree
with the idea that we should mind the
language itself for things that we need
he emphasizes of mining it for sentences
I don't agree I find it sentences are
all somewhat unique I prefer to mine
content from words and phrases but we
quibble
fundamentally it's the language that
teaches us but katsumoto's supposed to
have said and I haven't heard this from
him so I can't say that he did say it's
just attributed to him supposed to have
said that he doesn't like people who
claim to speak many languages because
they don't speak any of them well and he
finds it very unsatisfying to talk to
someone who doesn't have this depth in
the language well I don't I don't know
why they cut some would have said this
but if that was what said I mean I don't
I learned a language Japanese French
Spanish Chinese Russian mostly to
communicate with speakers of the
language not to communicate with other
learners so I communicate with native
speakers when I read and listen which is
what I mostly do because I don't know
many Russians here but if I meet a
Russian then I communicate with him or
her in Russian and if we are successful
in communicating I'm happy whether that
native speaker is interested in getting
to know me for whatever reason
including my ability in the language
well that's his choice or hers but for
us to say we don't respect other
language learners because they haven't
achieved a certain depth in our language
to me that's just silly what we do with
our languages is entirely our own affair
so I'm against the idea of perfection
I'm against the idea that we're
constantly worried about how well we
speak language learning is a personal
thing and and so far speaking with other
non-native speakers I have no interest
in speaking with other non-native
speakers and I would suggest that for
learners of language the further away
they get from other non-native speakers
without better especially from their own
language group and I think you know
whether it be in Japan or France or
places like that where people sit in
class or ting in an english-speaking
countries they sit in class with other
people who speak their own language and
hear them but there we can talk about
that wouldn't say much of the language
but that's not what you want to emulate
so you should really focus on listening
to the language spoken by native
speakers and but not pass judgment on
other people's learning efforts
everybody learns for their own reasons
everybody should feel satisfied with
whatever level they have achieved and if
they're motivated to do do more they
should continue and they will never
achieve perfection and so they may as
well enjoy it so there you have it